[Musik]
ZDF heute live willkommen zu unserem
Ukraine Update in dieser Woche in der
wir die Lage mit einem prominenten Gast
analysieren wollen und zwar Ben Hodges
dem ehemaligen Oberkommandeur der
usstitkräfte in Europa heute ist Tag
666 im Krieg in der
Ukraine in diesen Tagen erreichen uns
nur wenige Bilder aus den frontgebieten
wenig kann gesichert über die die
aktuelle Situation in der Ukraine gesagt
werden diese Soldaten kämpfen im Donbass
gegen die ukrainischen Truppen sie
beklagen Munitionsknappheit und stellen
sich auf einen langen und harten Winter
ein im für beide Seiten extrem
verlustreichen Kampf um die Stadt auf
dirfka meldeten zuletzt Russen Erfolge
doch die gibt es offenbar auch für die
Ukrainer diese Bilder die ihr jetzt seht
sollen zeigen wie bradleypanzer aus
US-Produktion russische Angriffe
abwehren ja kurz vor Ende dieses Jahres
wollen wir fragen was konnte die
ukrainische Gegenoffensive bewirken wie
sieht es aktuell an der Front aus und
worauf wird es jetzt ankommen dass die
Ukraine diesen Krieg doch noch gewinnen
kann dazu gleich zugeschaltet wie gesagt
Ben Hodges generalutnant ad der US Army
und ehemaliger Oberkommandeur der
us-stitkräfte in Europa außerdem
schalten wir gleich zu meiner Kollegin
Alisa jung nach Kiev wenn ihr euch jetzt
fragt warum sieht es hier anders aus als
ihr das von uns vielleicht gewohnt seid
wir mussten aus personellen Gründen in
ein anderes Studio umziehen deswegen
anderer Look aber natürlich keine
Abstriche beim Inhalt und auch in diesem
Stream und in diesem Setting wollen wir
natürlich auf so viele Fragen wie
möglich von euch eingehen deswegen
stellt sie gerne hier im Chat oder
schickt sie uns per Mail an
zdfheute-live@zdf.de und bevor ich jetzt
gleich mit Ben Hodges spreche wollen wir
euch unseren Gast einmal kurz vorstellen
Ben Hodges generalutnant ad der US-Armee
geboren in Quincy Florida Alter
65 seine Auslandseinsätze führen ihn ab
den 80er Jahren unter anderem nach
Deutschland Afghanistan und in den
Irak von 2014 an ist der
Oberkommandierender der US
Landstreitkräfte für Europa und die
Gebiete der
exsowjetstaaten einschließlich Russland
schon 2015 also nach der Krim Annexion
durch Russland und angesichts der Kämpfe
zwischen der ukrainischen Armee mit
prorussischen Separatisten vermutet hgis
Russland bereite sich auf einen Krieg
vor der 6 Jahre später stattfinden
könnte seit 2017 sein Ruhestand der
keiner ist denn hodgis beschäftigt sich
weiter mit Geopolitik und militärischer
Sicherheit und steht mit seiner
Expertise beratend zur
Verfügung und aus Frankfurt ist er mir
jetzt zugeschaltet guten Abend herrodes
good evening thank you for time even
vielen Dank also der Krieg in der
Ukraine wird von vielen expertinen und
Experten seit Wochen als Stellungskrieg
bezeichnet die Russen sehen wir rücken
bei avdka vor gleichzeitig machen die
Ukrainer im Süden bei Cherson offenbar
unter sehr extremen schwierigen
Umständen kleine Geländegewinne beide
Seiten verbuchen für sich Erfolge ihre
Einschätzung nach wo steht dieser Krieg
aktuell aus Sicht der
Ukraine
im Moment gibt es hier natürlich einen
Wendepunkt die ukrainische
Gegenoffensive ist nicht so gut gelaufen
wie gehofft ich lag falsch ich hatte die
das was erreicht werden könnte
überschätzt aber ich würde sagen das war
nicht wegen irgendetwas was die Ukraine
gemacht hat
sondern der Tatsache dass die Amerikaner
die Deutschen und andere europäische
Länder der ukine nicht das geliefert
haben was sie brauchen die Russen haben
jetzt eine eigene Gegenoffensive
gestartet haben Tausende von Soldaten
schon verloren und dafür so gut wie
nichts gewonnen wir sind jetzt in einer
Situation wo es praktisch ein Pat gibt
keine Seite hat im Moment wirklich die
Fähigkeit
durchzubrechen das ist spannend dass sie
das Sagen über die Unterstützung auch
von amerikanischer und von deutscher
Seite wollen wir gleich noch mal
sprechen der ukrainische Präsident
selenski hat vorgestern bei der Jahres
Pressekonferenz die Einschätzung
zurückgewiesen der Krieg habe sich zu
einem Pat entwickelt also wiedersprechen
sie
ihm nein das Wort das General tuschni
der Chef des grstabs gesagt
hat was er sagte ist nicht direkt ein
Pat sondern ein eine
sackkasse der Unterschied ist wenn der
Westen die richtigen Mittel liefern auch
die
Munition
dann wird es besser die russische seit
hat nicht die Fähigkeit die ukrainischen
Linien zu durchbrechen und die haben
keine positiven Lichter am Ende des
Tunnels also es geht jetzt darum diesen
unglücklichen Soldaten also die Russen
können praktisch nur ihre soldatenum
Fleischwolf bei aftivka schicken in der
Hoffnung dass wir im Westukraine nicht
malr richtig unterstützen also ich bin
optimistisch dafür dass die Ukraine den
Krieg gewinnen kann und nicht nur
überlebt wie das genau funktionieren
kann das wollen wir natürlich im Laufe
dieses Streams noch weiter besprechen
sie haben die stad afdfka und den Kampf
um die Stadt afdfka jetzt angesprochen
dieü die Russen Rücken da immer weiter
vor dabei ist die russische Führung
offenbar ziemlich unbeeindruckt davon
dass es sehr hohe Verluste gibt laut
ukrainischen und westlichen berichten
sind bei der Schlacht um aufdka bisher
18 000 bis 20.000 Soldaten gefallen die
Russen kommen trotzdem nur haben sie
gerade auch schon gesagt sehr langsam
voran trotzdem sterben eben tausende was
sagt das über die russische Strategie
aus was das zunächst mal sagt ist dass
die Russen nicht die Möglichkeit haben
tatsächlich durchzubrechen und wirklich
signifikante operative Vorteile
rauszuziehen sie gewinnen vielleicht ein
paar
Quadratkilometer aber der Preis dafür
ist unglaublich hoch und es ist ganz
klar dass sie erkennen dass sie die
Ukraine nicht besiegen können Sie warten
einfach drauf dass der Westen den Willen
verliert die Ukraine weiterhin zu
unterstützen in diesem Krieg und was sie
versuchen ist natürlich den Eindruck zu
schaffen als hen sie endlose Ressourcen
zur Verfügung das machen die dadurch
dass sie diese hunderte und aber
Hunderte von unglücklichen russischen
Soldaten in ihren Tod schicken in diesen
Fleischwolf und Sie haben Recht den ist
das völlig egal wie viele Verluste sie
haben und interessanterweise ist es so
dass kaum
Verluste aus Einheiten kommt die im St
Petersburg daherkmen oder aus Moskau
denn der Kremmel macht sich schon
Gedanken wie die öffentliche Wahrnehmung
ist also diese Soldaten im Fleischwolf
die kommen nicht aus Moskau oder St
Petersburg sondern die kommen aus
irgendwelchen anderen etthnischen
Regionen dazu muss man sagen dass in
Russland im nächsten Jahr der neue
Präsident gewählt wird der neue wird da
vermutlich der der alte sein m ist das
auch ein Grund für diesen sehr
erbitterten für diese sehr erbitterten
Kämpfe um afdfka also geht es auch darum
nach innen in politisch da ein Erfolg zu
präsentieren ja das ist natürlich eine
sehr gute Frage wenige von uns im Westen
verstehen tatsächlich was eigentlich in
Russland
passiert ich glaube nicht dass viele
Menschen in Russland selbst Zugang haben
zu
professionellen journalistischen
Arbeiten um sich da selber ein Bild zu
machen der Kremmel versucht natürlich
das narrativ zu kontrollieren
insbesondere jetzt vor den
Wahlen das ist natürlich eine scheinwahl
im Vergleich zu dem was in Europa oder
in USA oder in einer demokratischen
Gesellschaft erwarten würden aber es ist
eine Wahl und es ist interessant für
mich dass der Kremel zum einen sich
entschlossen hat zu versuchen Verluste
zu vermeiden von Menschen die aus St
Petersburg oder Moskau kommen zum
anderen haben Sie die große
Mobilmachung vor den
Wahlen gestoppt die Wahlen kommen ja im
März denn dann hätte der Kremmel
erklären müssen dass der Krieg
vielleicht nicht so gut läuft und dass
man hertausende neuer Truppen braucht
also es gibt schon eine gewisse
Sensitivität gegenüber der öffentlichen
Meinung in Russland Herr wir wollen
natürlich heute auch noch über
Waffenlieferungen sprechen wir bekommen
dazu die ganze Zeit auch Fragen bei
Youtube unter anderem fragt uns
Konstantinos wie viel Artilleriemunition
liefern die westlichen Staaten denn
aktuell an die Ukraine täglich wird hier
gefragt haben Sie dazu eine
Einschätzung also ich kann ihn natürlich
jetzt nicht sagen wie viel pro Tag
geliefert wde verbraucht wird aber es
geht natürlich um riesige Mengen mehr
als ich je gesehen habe in meinem Leben
mehr als wir jemals benutzt haben seit
dem Ende des Zweiten Weltkriegs die
Vereinigten Staaten haben für ihre
dieeri Munition die wir produzieren ver
viierfacht aber das ist immer noch nicht
ausreichend die Europäische Union hat
versprochen eine Millionen
Artilleriegeschosse für die Ukraine zu
produzieren wahrscheinlich wenn Sie die
Hälfte oder zwei Drittel davon schaffen
das reicht nicht die ukrainischen
Soldaten berichten ja dass sie schon die
Munition rationieren müssen weil sie
Angst haben nicht genug zu haben
gleichzeitig ist es so dass die Russen
aber auch ihre Schwierigkeiten haben sie
müssen praktisch Munition importieren
und zwar
Artilleriemunition geringe Qualität aus
Nordkorea und das zeigt einem wie
schwierig die Situation für die
russische
Verteidigungsindustrie ist und das
Logistiksystem die
Ukraine wird die in den nächsten Monaten
die russische Logistik sehr stark
angreifen denke ich daran noch
angeknüpft eine sehr große Frage aber
natürlich sehr berechtigt von Martin
rennike warum liefern die natoegierungen
denn nicht ausreichend an die
Ukraine eine hervorragende Frage wir
haben versagt im Westen wir haben die
russische Bedrohung nicht ernst genug
genommen wir haben nicht geglaubt dass
Russland jemals eine große Operation wie
diese im Februar damals starten würde
und niemand und dazu gehören auch die
USA niemand hat sich vorbereitet um die
entsprechenden Mengen und Arten der
mition vorzuhalten also so
Luftverteidigung
weitreichende Waffen
atteremunition wir brauchen jetzt Geld
und Ressourcen um die Industriebasis
unseres Landes zu erweitern das ist
machbar in Europa und in Kanada USA
können wir sicherlich mehr reichen als
was die Russen jereichen könnten aber
man braucht den politischen Willen
unsere politischen Führer müssen einfach
den Willen zeigen die Entschlossenheit
und dann das Geld investieren und die
Produktion
hochzufahren und die Russen wollen jetzt
natürlich schauen ob der Westen den
Willen hat die industrielle Kapazität
hat und die militärische Kapazität hat
der Ukraine zu helfen Russland zu
besiegen und oder auch werden wir
gleichzeitig Israel helfen können Hamas
zu besiegen und werden wir den
strategischen Problem im Indopazifik
gerecht werden können das S ein große
Herausforderung für uns alle her wir
wollen kurz vor dem Jahreswechsel
natürlich dieses Jahr auch noch einmal
bilanzieren vielleicht bevor wir gleich
zu meiner Kollegin in die Ukraine
schalten wir sprechen uns danach dann
noch mal weiter an Sie die Frage wenn
wir auf die ukrainische Strategie
schauen welche Fehler welche
maßgeblichen Fehler wurden da ihrre
Einschätzung nach gemacht und was hat
aber auch gut
funktioniert also was offensichtlich
sehr gut funktioniert aus UK
S oder für die ukrainische Seite war der
Druck auf die russische Marine in
Sebastopol drei Storm sch Mar Körper von
Großbritannien wurden genutzt um
Versorgungseinrichtungen der Marine in
sastopol zu zerstören und das zeigte
dass die entsprechend russischen
Einrichtungen dort sehr verwundbar sind
für länger reichende Waffen und das
heißt praktisch auch dass
langfristig sich die Russen auf der Krim
nicht halten können und die Marine
Schiffe mussten in sichere Häfen auf der
anderen Seite des schwarzmeers gebracht
werden also weiterreichende
Präzisionswaffen Drohnen und so weiter
haben eine sehr große Auswirkung sind
sehr effektiv was den Landkrieg angeht
die Ben Offensive der Gegenoffensive
lief nicht so gut wie ich gehofft und
erwartet hatte ich denke das hängt
einfach damit zusammen dass wir einfach
nicht die weitreichenden Waffen
geliefert haben die gebraucht worden
wären um russische Logistik und
Artillerie und befehlsstände zu
zerstören und die Vereinigten Staaten
und europäische Länder und Deutsch haben
so lange gebraucht um
F16 oder Kampfpanzer leopardpanzer zu
liefern und wir haben einfach viel zu
viel Zeit verstreichen lassen und die
Russen haben die Zeit genutzt wir haben
sehr langsam inkrementelle
Entscheidungen getroffen und deswegen
war es so dass die Ukrainer
diese schweren Verteidigungsanlagen
angreifen mussten und die F16 sind immer
noch nicht geliefert worden die Ukrainer
mussten angreifen ohne Luftunterstützung
die Vereinigten Staaten und die oder die
bundeswr würden die solche
Verteidigungseinrichtungen angreifen
ohne die Luft Überlegenheit zu haben und
wir haben das von der Ukraine Verlag
verlangt dafür sollten wir uns schämen
und wir sollten den Ukrainern helfen
diese Fähigkeiten zu bekommen sod dass
sie wieder die Initiative im neuen Jahr
ergreifen können Herr hes dann erstmal
vielen Dank für den Moment wir sprechen
uns gleich noch mal und wollen dann aus
kommende Jahr schauen und die Frage mit
Ihnen diskutieren was denn jetzt
passieren muss damit die Ukraine diesen
Krieg vielleicht noch für sich
entscheiden kann vielen Dank erstmal für
den
Moment und wir wollen jetzt gleich
einmal in die Ukraine schauen vorher
müssen wir uns aber einmal gemeinsam
anhören was der ukrainische Präsident
selenski vorgestern auf der
Jahrespressekonferenz über den Zustand
seiner Streitkräfte und die Mobilmachung
zusätzlicher Truppen gesagt
hat ihre Position in der generellen
stabssitzung war dass sie vorgeschlagen
haben zusätzlich 450 000 bis 500 000
Menschen zu
mobilisieren das ist eine sehr
ernstzunehmende Zahl und ich sagte dass
ich mehr Argumente brauche um diese Idee
zu
unterstützen das ist eine Frage über
Menschen über Gerechtigkeit über
verteidigungskapazitäten und auch eine
finanzielle
Frage
zu den Finanzen Mobilisierung in dieser
Größe würde die Ukraine zusätzlich 500
Milliarden
harosten fragen wir nach bei meiner
Kollegin Alissa jung in Kier Alisa das
ukrainische Militär will 450 000 bis
500.000 weitere Soldaten mobilisieren
wie kommt diese Zahl zustande was steckt
dahinter wir haben gehört das ist also
eine Forderung des Militärs das sind
also zusätzliche Soldaten die man
bräuchte um erschöpften Soldaten die
seit nun mal bald zwei Jahren an der
Front kämpfen eben eine Chance zu
ermöglichen eine Pause zu machen von der
direkten Frontlinie zurückzutreten also
zusätzliche Männer zu denen die jetzt
schon kämpfen wir haben es gehört es
gibt darüber jetzt also keine
Entscheidung fakt ist dass es immer mehr
Meldung darüber gibt dass die Soldaten
an den Frontlinien erschöpft sind und
wir haben hier heute in Kiev auch mit
einem Militär expert mit einem
ukrainischen darüber gesprochen wie
wichtig das ist aber auch welche
Herausforderungen es gibt lasst uns mal
gemeinsam in diesen Ton reinhören und
dann weiter darüber
sprechen wir sprechen nicht davon
Soldaten auszutauschen sondern
zusätzliche Männer zu mobilisieren um
die Reihen der Reservisten und jenen an
der Front aufzustocken wer jetzt
mobilisiert wird wird nicht vor dre
Monaten an der Front kämpfen können Sie
brauchen erst einmal ein Basistraining
und es muss geklärt werden in welcher
Einheit sie kämpfen würden diese Planung
obliegt dem Armeechef das ist mehr eine
technische als eine politische
Frage also eine organisatorische
Herausforderung aber dann auch noch das
es gibt einen Bericht des Wall Street
Journals die darüber sprechen ich
zitiere mal hier aus dem Artikel worüber
sie geschrieben haben dass es eben auch
massive Korruptionsfälle in den lokalen
Rekrutierungsbüros gäbe also das macht
es natürlich dann noch mal sehr viel
schwieriger und in diesen
Korruptionsfällen soll es also zu
häufigen Fällen gekommen sein wo soll
Daten es geschafft haben sich also
Papiere zu erkaufen whrpflichtige Männer
und sich dann ins Ausland abzusetzen das
ist natürlich dann noch eine zusätzliche
Herausforderung mit der man hier kämpft
also es wird gefordert mehr Menschen zu
rekrutieren aber dass es dazu kommt das
haben wir auch gerade in dem Ton des
Experten gehört davon ist man jetzt also
noch weit entfernt das heißt also jetzt
diesen Winter diesen harten Kampf den
müssen aktuell noch die Schultern die
also seit eben bald zwei Jahren schon an
der Front kämpfen Alissa du hast es
angesprochen also Ukrain ukrainische m
Männer die im Ausland sind in einem
Interview mit Bild hat der ukrainische
Verteidigungsminister Rustem ovierov
gesagt man überlege auch im Ausland
lebende Ukrainer
einzuziehen wie muss man sich das
vorstellen und wenn man dir jetzt gerade
zugehört hat ist das ja wohl nur sehr
schwer umsetzbar
richtig
absolut also auch da vielleicht gehen
wir jetzt erstmal ganz chronologisch
noch vor und ganz konkret was da gesagt
wurde in Bild zitiert aus diesem
Interview mit omerof spricht davon
Männer im whrpflichtigen Alter sollen
eine Aufforderung erhalten so hieß es
sich in den regierungszentren der
ukrainischen Streitkräfte zu melden das
ist das eine und sonst drohen ihnen
Sanktionen das hat Bild also auch noch
gesagt da gab es heute ein Dementi aus
dem Verteidigungsministerium der
Sprecher sagte man hätte mit Bild mit
dem Journalisten darüber also nur im
Allgemeinen gesprochen ist es ging darum
aufzufordern klarzumachen wie wichtig es
ist also in der Armee zu kämpfen das
war heute hier Thema und aber wenn wir
das jetzt mal genauer audröseln also
selbst wenn es so eine Aufforderung
geäbe wer würde dann tatsächlich
zurückkommen wohl kaum all jene die
davor geflohen sind zu kämpfen das ist
das eine das andere ist selbst wenn es
solche Sanktionen gäbe und davon soll ja
jetzt also gar keine Rede mehr sein die
Realität ist diese dass in Deutschland
beispielsweise die all jene die aus der
Ukraine hingeflohen sind auch Aufenthalt
genießen das ist so festgelegt worden
das heißt also es bräuchte quasi ein
einer ausweisungsgesuch was die Ukraine
bei den Ländern stellen müsste um die
Menschen überhaupt zurückholen zu können
und das ist auch nicht so einfach weil
dazu müsste ihn erstmal eine Straftat
nachgewiesen werden also es ist eine
große Headline aber wenn man genauer
hinschaut dann bleibt davon einfach
wenig
übrig dann lass uns noch einmal an die
Front schauen wir hören immer wieder du
hast es gerade auch schon gesagt
Berichte von Soldaten die ja über
extreme Erschöpfung klagen welche
Informationen liegen dir gerade vor über
die Verfassung über die Situation der
Soldaten an der
Front es sind vor allem ihre Frauen die
diesen Protest auf die Straße tragen und
auch diese Message auf die Straße tragen
die eben darüber berichten dass ihre
Männer so erschöpft sein also da kommt
es immer wieder auch zu Protesten von
bis zu 100 Frauen die auf der Straße
stehen mit Schildern die berichten
darüber dass seit bald nun mehr zwei
Jahren Kampf ihre Männer erschöpft sind
wenig Pausen haben wenn sie verletzt
sind leicht verletzt sind auch wieder
sehr schnell zurückkehren müssten an die
Front also darum genau darum geht es
dass all jene die vielleicht denen jetzt
langsam die Kraft fehlt denen die Puste
ausgeht dass die schon natürlich weiter
kämpfen deren Moral ist ja auch nach wie
vor hoch aber dass ihnen einfach eine
Möglichkeit gegeben wird sich auch mal
von der direkten Frontlinie
zurückzuziehen in in eine ja in in mit
etwas Abstand und dass einfach andere
Männer an der Front kämpfen dass all
jene dann wieder gestärkt an die Front
zurückkehren können die eben aktuell in
allererster Linie
stehen danke dir für diese Eindrücke und
für diese Einschätzung live aus Kiev
Alissa jung vielen
Dank ja wir wollen uns jetzt noch mal
den Blick aufs nächste Jahr richten wir
bekommen dazu bei von euch natürlich die
ganze Zeit auch schon viele Fragen wenn
es darum geht um Waffenlieferung um
weitere Unterstützung von westlichen
Staaten und das will ich jetzt gerne
noch einmal weiter vertiefen mit Ben
Hodges dem ehemaligen Oberkommandeur der
usstitkräfte der mir jetzt hoffentlich
noch mal aus Frankfurt zugeschaltet ist
hallo noch mal Herr Hodges grüße sie
hallo ja hallo also wir hören immer
wieder Berichte von einem langsamen
vorrücken bei Cherson im Südosten der
Ukraine da haben es die ukrainischen
Streitkräfte offenbar geschafft eine
Spezialeinheit auf die südöstliche Seite
des nipro
vorzurücken es gibt auch Berichte von
diesen Streitkräften von diesen
Einheiten die dort von einem Zitat
Himmelfahrtskommando sprechen um was
geht es dort für die Ukraine aktuell an
dieser
Stelle natürlich waren die ukrainischen
Kräfte in der Lage eine brückenh Kopf
auf der auf dem linken Ufer des ni zu
schaffen und die sind da natürlich sehr
verwundbar und die Leute sprechen
natürlich von sehr extremen Dingen Lenn
das Himmelfahrtskommando aber der
Generalstab hat natürlich einen Grund
warum man das macht wenn man einen
Brückenkopf auf der anderen Seite des
Flusses hat dann W es wenn die Zeit
gekommen ist einfacher sein Brücken zu
bauen und mehr schwere Waffen und
Ausrüstung rüber zu bringen die Soldaten
die da jetzt sind die sind natürlich
sehr verwundbar und ich denke der
Generalstab versucht die Soldaten auch
zu schützen aber man muss irgendwann
Entscheidung treffen wenn man sie nicht
schützen kann wenn es das Risiko nicht
wert ist dann werd man sie zurückziehen
man will natürlich solche so ein Gelände
nicht aufgeben auf der anderen Seite des
Flusses aber hat das wenn wir jetzt noch
mal sozusagen auf die Wirkung schauen
die davon ausgehen soll wir haben jetzt
über sozusagen das Signal was nach
Russland gesendet werden soll durch den
Kampf oder eine mögliche Einnahme der
Stadt aufdfka ist das möglicherweise
vergleichbar aus ukrainischer
Perspektive also geht es auch darum
diesen kleinen diese kleinen
Geländegewinne die man da jetzt machen
konnte auch zu halten um der Bevölkerung
auch in dieser aktuellen Situation ein
Erfolg präsentieren zu
können ja vielleicht ist das ein Teil
dessen was die Russen erreichen wollen
bisher haben sie ziemlich wenig
erreicht und nichts erreicht was den
Stopp derukischen Gegenoffensive angeht
Ste
spezielleitäroperation sein für den
Kremmel und jetzt z Jahre später haben
sie nur 17% der Ukraine mit 315000 an
Verlusten also es gibt keinen Grund zum
Optimismus auf der russischen Seite
außer wenn wir im Westen zeigen dass wir
den Willen verlieren die Ukraine zu
unterstützen avdivka ist ein Ort wo die
Russen bereitind tausende für
Menschenleben zu opfern so wie bei
bachmut aber wofür es gibt da wirklich
keinen wirklichen Zweck und die Ukraine
scheint da doch ein bisschen
vorsichtiger gewesen zu sein was den
Umgang mit dem Leben ihrer Soldaten
umgeht natürlich haben die Ukrainer
viele Soldaten verloren aber sie sind
sehr vorsichtig wenn es drum geht was
sie mit den Soldaten machen die auf der
anderen Seite deser jetzt
sind aliciia ihre Reporter hat paar
interessante Sachen gesagt die dazu in
Beziehung stehen natürlich ist so dass
die ukrainis Truppen erschöpft sind und
ich denke mir dass der Generalstab in
den nächsten Monaten versuchen wird
einige dieser Einheiten
zurückzuziehen um damit ihr sich wieder
erholen können an einerit die vielleicht
schon nonstop mehrere Monate gekämpft
hat die wir dann zurückgezogen um
auszuruhen oder um beschädigte
Ausrüstung zu ersetzen oder Uniformen
auszubessern oder die Verluste
auszugleichen und dann wieder bisschen
Ausbildung zu machen und sich auszuruhen
ich denke wir werden das sehen das
passiert sicherlich nicht auf der
russischen Seite denn denen ist das egal
und ich würde ungern ein russischer
Soldat im Schützengraben sein denn
niemand kümmert sich um die und die
Logistik der Russen liefert nicht das
was die Leute da brauchen das ist anders
als auf der ukrainischen Seite Herr hchz
dann lassen Sie uns gerne noch einmal
auf die von Ihnen jetzt gerade auch noch
mal angesprochene Unterstützung auch aus
den USA schauen also Joe Biden will der
Ukraine Hilfen im Umfang von 61
Milliarden Dollar zur Verfügung stellen
die Republikaner blockieren das im
November kommenden Jahres sind in den
USA die
Präsidentschaftswahlen die Republikaner
knüpfen Ihre Zustimmung an Ukraine
Hilfen zunehmt an Bedingungen dazu
angeschlossen die Frage von Neft Schmidt
die wir bei Youtube bekommen haben wann
kommt endlich Hilfe aus den USA für die
Ukraine ja
das ist eine gute Frage das ist wirklich
peinlich für mich dass unser
Kongress
tatsächlich sich eine politische Debatte
leistet wenn wir eigentlich strategisch
nachdenken
müssten wenn es drum geht demokratischen
Länder zu helfen gegen autokratischen
faschistischen Diktaturen zu
kämpfen die Partei Ronald Regans die
republikanische Partei stand immer stark
gegen Russland und die
Sowjetunion und die Republikaner im
Kongress sind eigentlich nur ganz wenige
die suchen jetzt politische Vorteile
denn die Einwanderung in die
USA wird sicherlich das Thema Nummer ein
bei den Präsidentschaftswahlen sein
und weil die wissen dass Präsident Biden
und die Demokraten die Ukraine so stark
unterstützen wollen nutzen Sie diese
Debatte über das hilfpaket als einen
Hebel um von den Demokraten im
Verhandlungsprozess
Zugeständnisse zu gewinnen Veränderungen
in Bezug auf die gegenwärtige
Asylpolitik und diese Dinge sind für
viele Menschen auf der linken völlig
unakzeptabel die Republikaner wissen
das aber denen ist die
einwanderungsfrage sehr sehr wichtig als
großes Thema für die Wahlen im November
das ist den wichtiger als alles andere
und sie sind bereit die Hilfen
zurückzuhalten und das ist natürlich
frischer Sauerstoff für den Kremmel ich
denke irgendwann wird das gelöst werden
im Februar denke ich vielleicht ein
bisschen vorher aber ich schätze es wird
februar werden aber der Schaden wird
dann getan
sein da werden
Verwundbarkeiten in unserer Innenpolitik
aufgezeigt die Ironie ist dass die
meisten Amerikaner ja die Ukraine
unterstütz und auch die meisten
Republikaner aber es gibt eine kleine
Gruppe von Rechten Extremisten der
repblikis Partei alles was denen wichtig
ist ist an die Macht zu kommen ich würde
ihn gerne noch eine Frage weitergeben
die wir von Andreas bekommen haben und
zwar wenn wir jetzt auf die
Präsidentschaftswahl im kommenden Jahr
schauen wie würde es weitergehen mit der
militärischen Unterstützung sollte Trump
wieder Präsident
werden wir machen uns wir werden uns
alle dann natürlich ein bisschen mehr
Sorgen wenn Herr Trump wieder gewählt
wird auf der Grundlage seiner Ablehnung
oder seiner Verachtung für die Ukraine
in Vergangenheit und seinem Lob was er
für Präsident Putin und andere
Diktaturen übrig hatte und ehrlich
gesagt er versteht nicht wirklich worum
es hier
geht und meine europäischen Freunde und
Verbündeten müssen sich bereit machen
mehr zu tun der deutsche Minister sagte
vor kurzem falls die Amerikaner ihre
Pflicht nicht
tun wenn wir unsere pflichtig tun wird
die Bedrohung immer noch da sein Europa
wird bedroht sein und die europäischen
Länder müssen sich darauf vorbereiten
auf diese
Möglichkeit ich würde sagen mit Blick
auf die
Präsidentschaftswahlen es fängt ja im
Januar an mit den Primaries mit den
Vorwahlen in Iowa New hampire South
Carolina und wir werden da mehr
herausfinden und ich denke wir werden
feststellen dass die Trump Kampagne
einiges an Dynamik verlieren wird ich
würde nicht sagen dass die Wahlen schon
gelaufen sind was seine Nominierung
angeht oder dass er auch nur die oder
dass er die Wahl gewinnt ja die
Ergebnisse die Umfragen zeigen dass
Trump in einer starken Position ist aber
Umfragen sind Indikatoren keine
Voraussagen so denken die Leute jetzt
und die meisten Amerikaner die machen
sich erst ernsthafte Gedanken um die
Wahlen wenn die Wahlen nur noch ein paar
Wochen entfernt istind Außenpolitik
internationale Fragen die spielen selten
eine große Rolle in der amerikanischen
Politik der gegenwärtige Präsident muss
jetzt seine Hausaufgaben machen er muss
ehrlich gesagt besser daran arbeiten zu
erklären was in den USA wirtschaftlich
passiert die wirtschaftliche Lage ist
gut wegen seiner Politik und er muss
auch erklären warum die Hilfe für die
Ukraine gut ist für die amerikanische
Sicherheit er muss das
tun es geht nicht nur um Gouverneur des
santtis oder früheren früher
Gouverneurin hay das sind die
Herausforderer auf der
republikanischen Seite zusätzlich dazu
hat Trump rechtliche Probleme einige
werden noch dauern bis nach den
Wahlen er kann aber nicht alles
erledigen ich denke diese Dinge werden
immer weiter in der for kommen das eine
Art
schneebalffekt und die Leute werden
anfangen nachzudenken der ist glaube ich
nicht wählbar warum sollte ich meine
Stimme und mein Geld verschwenden auf
jemanden der vielleicht als Verbrecher
verurteilt wird also ich bin da durchaus
optimistisch dass Trump nicht
wiedergewählt wird als Präsident okay
Herr hes dann lassen Sie uns gerne noch
mal auf die tatsächlich auf die
Unterstützung der Ukraine schauen wenn
wir jetzt davon ausgehen dass die
militärische Unterstützung seitens der
USA nachlässt welche Rolle kommt dann
sie haben gerade schon die europäischen
Partner angesprochen aber welche Rolle
kommt dann ganz konkret Deutschland
zu Deutschland ist die führende Nation
in Europa in der Europäischen Union
Deutschland ist ein führendes
natomitglied und der wichtigste
bündespartner der USA als ich in
der Armee war ich bin jetzt außerdienst
aber als ich in Armee war haben wir
stark dran gearbeitet die Schäden an der
amerikanischdeutschen Beziehungen
aufzuarbeiten und ich sehe das jetzt die
Deutschen und unsere wichtigsten
btnispartner aber die Vereinigten
Staaten haben natürlich auch große
Erwartungen ich würde sagen Deutschland
die meisten Deutschen wissen glaube ich
gar nicht dass Deutschland der
zweitgrößte Unterstützer der Ukraine ist
und da geht z die Patriot
Luftverteidigungssystem die von
Deutschland die Ukraine gehen das ist
ganz ganz wichtig
das rettet hunderte von Menschen
leben und über 100 mer das ist ein sehr
guter deutscher Schützenpanzer noch mal
100 dieser Schützenpanzer werden an die
Ukraine geliefert also Deutschland
leistet sehr viel das eine was
Deutschland noch nicht getan hat und das
würde wirklich einen Unterschied
bereiten das wäre das taurusystem das
ist ein exzellenter markörper mit einer
Reichweite von 500 km das würde wirklich
eine große Veränderung bringen als
Waffensystem und ich verstehe nicht
warum Deutschland diese Fähigkeit nicht
an die Ukraine liefern will das ist eine
Diskussion die in diesem Jahr sehr
ausgiebig geführt wurde und bisher zu
keinem abschließenden Ergebnis gekommen
ist Herr Hodges dann lassen Sie uns noch
einmal gerne den Blick aufs nächste Jahr
oder auf die nächste Zeit richten wenn
ich sie Frage nach was wären drei Dinge
die jetzt passieren müssten oder ein
absehbarer Zeit passieren müssten damit
die Ukraine diesen Krieg für sich
gewinnt tolle Frage zunächst mal Nummer
eins die Vereinigten Staaten Deutschland
andere führende demokratische Nationen
sollten erklären dass es unsere Politik
ist und unser Ziel ist dass die Ukraine
diesen Krieg gewinnt dass sie Russland
zurückführt auf die Grenz von
1991 das wäre ganz wichtig das würde den
Russen sagen dass ihre Hoffnung dass wir
aufgeben falsch
ist und dann würden wir auch keine
Entschuldigungen mehr brauchen um der
Ukraine nicht die Waffen zu geben die
sie braucht um zu gewinnen das zweite
wichtige ist die Lieferung von
weitreichenden Präzisionswaffen mit mit
denen man russische kommandostäbe und
Artillerie und
Logistik beschießen kann und ausheben
kann und dafür zu sorgen dass die
russische Marine keine Platz im
schwarzen mehr hat und dann die
F16 für den
Kampf es gibt noch nicht so
viele polioten die dasugze Fliegen
können ist es eine Sache ein Flugzeug zu
fliegen etwas anderes damit zu kämpfen
und wenn bis zum Sommer diese F16
geliefert würden das würde schon sehr
viel bedeuten Herres wir bekommen
weiterhin Fragen ich würde ihn gerne
noch einmal eine stellen ihre
Einschätzung zur möglichen
Verhandlungsbereitschaft von Vladimir
Putin dem russischen Präsident und zwar
fragt uns jemand bei youtube ist Putin
tatsächlich nach wie vor unter keinen
Umständen zu Verhandlungen mit der
Ukraine bereit müsste wahrscheinlich
auch andersrum Fragen ist die Ukraine
bereit mit dem russischen Präsidenten zu
verhandeln also wie schätzt sie diese
Situation aktuell
ein ich denke dass Wladimir Putin
ziemlich deutlich gemacht hat in seiner
berümten Pressekonferenz am Ende des
Jahres vor ein paar Tagen dass er kein
Interesse an Verhandlungen hat bis sie
nicht ihre Ziele erreicht haben und er
spricht ja von der Entnazifizierung der
Ukraine und es ist ein andere Art zu
sagen bis sie die Ukraine als stat
zerstört haben oder die Idee der Ukrain
Staat er hat kein Interesse an
Verhandlungen ich denke das verändert
sich das wird sich verändern wenn er
sieht dass er die Krim verloren hat denn
das wäre dann sehr schwierig für ihn zu
erklären gegenüber seinen Unterstützern
und ich sprechen nicht nur über die 140
Millionen Russen sondern auch die 50
oder 100 Oligarchen um ihn herum die so
viel verlieren weil sie Putin
unterstützen und dann wird er ein
Problem bekommen ich denke irgendwann
sobald er feststellt dass er den Krieg
verliert wenn er sieht dass die
Vereinigten Staaten und Deutschland
entschlossen sind der Ukraine zu helfen
zu gewinnen dann wird er seine Haltung
ändern ich habe keine großen Erwartungen
dass das bald passiert und was die
Ukraine angeht sie wissen dass sie nie
in der Lage sein werden ihre
Volkswirtschaft aufzubauen solange
Russland die Krim besetzt hält die
russischen Truppen und die Marine
Russlands die blockieren die Krim
der im ME
und sie blockieren Zugang zu Odessa
nikolev und andere Orte andere Häfen
also die Ukraine
kann nicht aufhören solange Russland die
Krim besetzt hält wir haben es von
meiner Kollegin Alissa jung aus Kiev
gerade auch schon gehört es gibt
Berichte von sehr extrem von extrem
erschöpften ukrainischen Soldaten von
Frauen von Familien die wollen dass ihre
Männer nach Hause kommen sehen Sie die
Gefahr dass der Ukraine perspektivisch
Soldaten
fehlen also ich habe genau zugehört was
aliciia gesagt hat die Ukraine hat
eigentlich
kein Problem mit den Soldaten s ein
Problem mit dem System geht eine Million
von UK
im re Alter die
initkräftenen könen eine Million das
reicht dass die Ukraine Erfolg sein kann
und Krieg gewinnen kann aber deren
System hat so viele Probleme ein Teil
davon ist
Korruption ein Teil davon ist eine
altertümliche bürokratische
Administration das muss man einfach
reparieren die müssen es attraktiv
machen für die Taus ischen
Männern die in Deutschland leben und
arbeiten oder in Polen oder in Rumänien
sodass sie auch zurückkommen wollen
junge Männer
im militärischen Alter die wollen doch
ihren Land dien da geht's um den Stolz
auf die Familie stolz auf ihre Nation
die müssen an ihre Zukunft denken aber
Sie müssen wissen dass wenn Sie
zurückkommen dass sie in ein System
kommen das gut organisiert ist wo sie
ausgebildet werden und wo man sich um
ihre Familien kümmert die Ukraine muss
das einfach in Ordnung bringen das ist
ganz wichtig für die kriegsanstrengung
der Ukraine für uns ist es wichtig den
Ukrainern die richtige Mittel zu geben
aber die haben sichtausende von Menschen
im militärischen
Alter die bereit stehen würden ich
glaube das ganze System dort muss
einfach effizienter werden sod dass sie
tatsächlich diese vielen potenziellen
Soldaten nutzen können die sie
eigentlich hätten her dann lassen Sie
uns vielleicht abschließen wir haben
jetzt viel darüber gesprochen und ihn
zugehört was passieren müsste im besten
Fall aus ihrer Sicht wenn wir trotzdem
jetzt noch mal den Blick nach vorne
richten wie wird dieser Krieg ihrer
Einschätzung nach dann tatsächlich in
den kommenden Monaten verlaufen wie wird
es
weitergehen das letztendliche Ergebnis
hät natürlich von den Vereinten Staaten
Deutschland und anderen bndespartnern
ab wenn wir
nicht das tun was getan werden muss dann
wird das länger dauern als nötig wir
sind am Steuerhebel wir können das
Beschleunigen wenn wir ernsthaft daran
arbeiten das ist der erste Punkt in den
nächsten Monaten was ich da erwarte ist
dass die ukrainischen streitkäfte ihre
Fähigkeit
verbessern im elektronischen Krieg gegen
die Russen zu bestehen auch was die
drohen angeht die Russen sind das schon
sehr gut geworden und die Ukrainer
müssen Fähigkeiten auch verbessern und
die werden hart dran arbeiten Ihr
System der Rekrutierung zu verbessern
und Sie werden über weitreichende Waffen
versuchen die russische Logistik
auszunehmen auch über auch per Sabotage
und sie werden versuchen Ihre eigene
Verteidigungsindustrie zu verbessern die
Ukraine war ja mal das Herz der
Verteidigungsindustrie der Sowjetunion
die wissen wie das geh sie müssen da
wieder neu
anfangenal und andere reinmetall und
andere fir BME helfen jetzt der
ukrainischen
Verteidigungsindustrie und ich denke da
werden wir noch viel mehr sehen in den
nächsten Monaten sagt Ben Hodges
ehemaliger Oberkommandeur der US
Streitkräfte in Europa vielen Dank für
Ihre Zeit heute abend thank you so
much ich danke Ihnen für
dieögit ich wünsche allen Zuschauern
schöne
Festtage danke schön das wünschen wir
auch das war unser Ukraine Update in
dieser Woche wenn ihr aktuelle
Informationen dazu bekommen möchtet
Analysen Hintergründe dann findet ihr
die auch jederzeit in der ZDF hte App
danke euch für heute fürs zuschauen
danke für eure ganzen Fragen und
Kommentare und bis zum nächsten
Mal